bonjour fabien golfier merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france alors appel de
quatre des neuf syndicats de la fonction
publique aujourd'hui
pouvez vous nous en dire plus sur ses
revendications alors il vous a pas
échappé à queue de cuisses de nombreux
mois ce sont les fonctionnaires qui sont
en première ligne pour accompagner le
pays dans la crise sanitaire qui a que
nous subissons tous
la plupart de ces fonctionnaires sont
plus souvent ceux qui sont les moins
bien rémunérés de la fonction publique
j'entends par là qu'il y a peu de temps
à la ministre sont au regret de devoir
d'avoir ramené à l'est les traitements
indiciaires des fonctionnaires en fait
qui fait là référence de leur salaire au
niveau du smic alors que depuis de
nombreux mois en fait un fonctionnaire
et est statutairement payer moins que le
smic c'était un rattrapage ce n'est en
aucun cas une augmentation moi je vous
interrogerez simplement c'est que tous
les jours à l'heure où nous parlons ce
matin d'ici quelques minutes
tout le monde va reprendre son activité
professionnelle rejoindre par exemple en
est son enfant à l'école
est ce que quelqu'un s'est jamais
interrogé quel était le le salaire de la
personne qui accueille et sept enfants à
l'école un fonctionnaire catégorie c est
payé au smic à l'heure actuelle avec la
réévaluation qui a été fait par parité
un fonctionnaire de catégorie b en début
de carrière est payé à peine 40 euros au
dessus du smic
un fonctionnaire de catégorie à un
caractériel et ses hommes baca catégorie
a c'est un peu plus élevé est levée et
payer quelques centaines d'euros dessus
ce ne sont pas des nantis ses agents ont
été en première ligne tout le long de la
crise ils ont été les seuls contacts
parfois pour la plupart de la population
et pour autant ce sont parmi les plus
bas salaire de france pour la plupart
d'entre eux on a quand même des agents
publics notamment la collecte et hérite
orial qui sont en précarité totale alors
qu'ils sont à salariés à plein temps
ces six situations qui sont complètement
hallucinante qui ne seraient pas
tolérées et que l'état critique
lorsqu'il s'agit d'entreprises privées
mais que l'état et vallées
administration générale ils sont
capables d'appliquer à l'ensemble des
agents qu'ils emploient une grande
partie des gens qu'ils emploient donc ce
que l'on demande tout simplement c'est
une vraie négociation salariale et non
pas du saupoudrage ne va pas échappé
qu'il ya quelques semaines de ça
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
ont saisi la ministre justement sur ce
sujet et demandant une vraie politique
salariale pour les agents publics
la ministre a répondu que ce n'était pas
le sujet un gros que nous n'étions pas
dans la mesure de lui demander cette
cette démarche notre le monde c'est de
se saisir de cette démarche
alors là le calendrier se bousculer un
petit peu parce que nos quatre horizons
syndicales avaient déjà anticipé cette
journée du 15
pendant ce temps là les neuf
organisations syndicales représentatives
des fonctionnaires ou toujours une
démarche vis-à-vis de la ministre rien
est stoppé et nous attendons de cette
journée aujourd'hui de laisser la
possibilité à nos collègues de
s'exprimer et de faire valoir leurs
demandes
nous avons de toute façon également avec
nos collègues des autres agressions
syndicale qui on aurait souhaité qu'ils
soient là également jacno aujourd'hui
mais un certain d'entre eux localement
seront présents que nos collègues avec
nos collègues nous maintenons cette
demande d'un vrai rendez vous salarial
et non pas de deux soupoudrage comme ça
il est plus question d'avoir de
revalorisation il faut être proactif
il faut rappeler que la fonction
publique a c'est une vraie valeur
ajoutée pour le pays
c'est un investissement cet
investissement nous a permis de tenir
pendant plus d'un an alors que si jamais
on avait dû reporter une partie des
services public sur le privé il est
évident qu'une partie de la population
et d'essai était laissée à l'abandon
faute de droite et gauche sur tout le
territoire
fabien golfier vous parlez d'une
politique destructrice de la fonction
publique quelles conséquences
justement de ces bas salaires sur sur
sur l'activité c'est surtout ça démotive
jean déjà d'une première dans un premier
temps et ça n'incite pas des jeunes à
demain venir rejoindre la fonction
publique c'est pas incitatif
ça donne pas envie quelque part à force
de détruire la fonction publique d'en
détruire l'image et d'oublier que c'est
une vraie valeur ajoutée pour le pays on
se rend compte que les jeunes préfèrent
à partir vers le privé on se rend compte
également à l'heure actuelle que dans la
fonction publique hospitalière
bon nombre d'agents démissionne et d'une
part faute de moyens pour pouvoir
exercer correctement leur métier
d'autre part parce que les salaires sont
moins en moins attractif avec la
pénibilité excellent traîne derrière et
bien les six agents partent travailler
dans le privé doit tout simplement
demain si on veut une fonction publique
qui nous permettent de maintenir la
qualité de service public et ce qui est
quand même le ciment en fait de notre
pays parce que c'est là on retrouve en
fait des histoires de maison commune
nommée rice et les maisons communes de
nous de nos collectivités
c'est l'endroit où l'essentiel des
services publics ati demain on n'a plus
d'argent public a pour pouvoir
pierre a fonctionné ces services comment
va-t-on faire
on va tout déléguer au privé il est bien
évident que si demain aux demandes la
même réactivité et les mêmes exigences
d'une sas d'un service privé on n'aura
pas la même qualité
c'est pas que le lait les entreprises
privées ne sache pas faire c'est que
tout simplement un service public c'est
déjà une continuité de service c'est
déjà des agents qui sont sollicités
régulièrement dans des domaines qui
parfois dépassent parce qu'on a souvent
des agents qui sont de catégorie à qui
on demande d'effectuer des missions de
catégorie b
mais parfois c'est juste parce que l'on
manque d'effectif pas ce qu'on leur
demande plus qu'ils ne sont normalement
payé et rémunéré pour faire il ya le
service public c'est vraiment un
engagement au delà même d'un travail
c'est un engagement parce que ces agents
s'inscrivent dans une démarche qui va
faire que ils vont avoir un salaire qui
va certes régulièrement augmenté tous
les deux trois quatre ans en fonction de
leur grille mais il n'y a pas de
négociation dans le même temps on
détruit aussi
simon parce que l'équité qui devrait y
avoir au sein appliqué normalement il
puis le pire dans tout ça c'est que ce
sont les femmes qui en sont les victimes
les premières victimes
parce que on répartit le salaire donc il
ya traitement indiciaire qui est la base
de tout fonctionnaire et en même temps
on joue sur les régimes indemnitaires
qu'ils se trompaient équivalent dans
tous les services publics et dans toutes
parts dans toutes les collectivités
chaque collectivité peut s'emparer du
service et de la rémunération qu'elle
souhaite en matière de de complément des
traitements
il est évident demain le problème le
problème serait justement c'est là le
point d'indicé qui reste gelé qui ça y
est il est rémunéré
c'est la référence en fait c'est notre
référence pour calculer un salaire le
point d'indicé touche ensemble des
fonctionnaires c'est ce qui accule
égales pour l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires le point d'indicé
c'est la même chose pour tout agent
qu'il soit de catégorie cette catégorie
burqa theolia c'est le nombre de points
qui fait le traitement indiciaire qui
fait salaires mais par contre s'ils
évoluent ils évoluent pour tous et on se
rend compte que lorsqu'on commence à
vouloir réunir et essentiellement avec
des régimes indemnitaires
seuls les fonctionnaires de catégorie a
les plus élevés traîne des régimes
indemnitaires assez conséquent et ceux
qui sont les moins bien rémunérés dans
ces conditions là ce sont les deux
fonctions catégorie c et il est encore
moins bien rémunérés sont souvent les
femmes
donc en fait il n'y a absolument aucune
égalité à vouloir modifier le
fonctionnement et le la rémunération des
fonctionnaires en gens sur les liens
militaires
il faut renforcer le traitement
indiciaire stade et renforcer le point
d'indicé et même le nombre de points en
fonction de sa catégorie et xhaka et
chaque salle et chaque filière de façon
à ce qu'ils aient au moins une
rémunération qui soit équitable pour
tous et qu'ils ne fassent pas de
différenciation et l'a réellement
lorsque lors on ne travaille plus
uniquement sur régime militaire mais sur
le point d'indicé à ce moment là on fait
évoluer les salaires pour l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires à catégorie un niveau
égal quelles que soient les hommes les
femmes et ces jeunes un rendez-vous est
déjà fixé pour le 6 juillet prochain
c'est un rendez vous trop tardive des
doudous rendez vous à ce qu on sait déjà
qu'un mini de montchalin c'est
complètement opposés à une aux
généralités généralisée pardon des
salaires un ca ca nous à nous a répondu
dans un courrier adressé à l'ensemble
des réactions syndicales à ce sujet
c'est sauf qu'elle n'a pas l'outil s'est
pas c'est pas le bon outil se dire
opposés oui très bien mais à nous ils
expliquent pourquoi parce que si on
n'est pas en capacité d'augmenter ses
agents il en fait juste d'apporter une
reconnaissance parce que c'est pas
l'effet de la prime qu'ovide qui a eu
quelques effets sur les âmes nation
parce que tous ne l'ont pas perçu
notamment les connectiques territoriale
où ça relève d'une délibération
c'est un régime indemnitaire libre
administration et politiques à et oriane
n'y a pas eu d'obligation d'inverser ce
qui est une vraie reconnaissance pour
les agents c'est un salaire décent et
qui leur permettent de survivre
on ne peut plus continuer à voir arriver
un traitement indiciaire pour un agent
public qui soit en dessous du smic
aude certes l'état n'est pas en capacité
de suivre l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat
de l'inflation et c'est comme les comme
le fait autrement les entreprises
privées mais à ce moment là il faut
avoir un salaire merci beaucoup fabien
golfier on n'a plus le temps
malheureusement on va suivre évidemment
cette grève de la fonction publique
aujourd'hui sur notre antenne merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france ce matin